[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Álvaro Cordero el
asesinato el pasado 16 de septiembre de
masamine por la policía de la moral
trasera paleada por no llevar
correctamente puesto el velo ha desatado
una fuerte ola de protestas que ha
sacudido Irán en el último mes las
mujeres han liderado este movimiento
contra las estrictas leyes que atentan a
sus derechos más básicos una situación
que no siempre fue así pero que lleva
dándose desde el año 1979 cuando triunfó
la revolución islámica e Irán se
convirtió en una teocracia en France 24
repasamos este momento de la historia
durante las primeras siete décadas del
siglo XX Irán estaba muy lejos de ser el
país que es ahora esta nación era una
monarquía que desde 1926 estaba
regentada por la dinastía palavi para
los años previos a la revolución su
soberano era Elsa mohamad reza palavi
una figura muy cercana a Estados Unidos
que trató de realizar varias reformas en
su país con el fin de occidentalizarlo
los años del Sas se han caracterizado
por la liberación de la economía iraní
La abolición del velo o la ampliación de
de los derechos de las mujeres durante
sus gobiernos este colectivo llegó a
tener derecho a voto derecho al divorcio
y casi una total libertad personal
Aunque a pesar de sus concesiones
sociales en el aspecto político este
monarca se caracterizó por su gran
represión contra disidentes y opositores
que osaran desafiarlo algo que generó un
gran malestar en diver suscriptores de
la sociedad iraní los miles de detenidos
y cientos de fallecidos hicieron que a
finales de 1978 las protestas crecieran
contra El Monarca y su familia a quien
acusaban de liderar un régimen tirano y
profundamente corrupto tras estas
protestas había un Crisol de personas a
las que solamente les unía su rechazo
total a la monarquía algunos de los
opositores eran comunistas otros eran
estudiantes liberales de los entornos
urbanos Y por último también había
fundamentalistas islámicos la
occidentalización que había liderado
Elsa sentó muy mal al colectivo
religioso ultraconservador que veía en
ellas una amenaza a la forma de vida
tradicional iraní durante las protestas
este grupo consiguió hacerse mayoritario
y ganar cada vez más fuerza en torno a
la figura de un gran líder el
ayatolágeno estas eran sus palabras
desde su exilio en París meses antes de
tomar el poder
que sea una abdicación a una dimisión no
significa nada pero el sea tiene que ser
retirado de su trono el voto del pueblo
ya no es el ya y tiene que ser retirado
de su trono
tras su destitución se establecerá la
república islámica que se basará en el
voto popular general
la victoria de la Revolución depuso al
sa e hizo que Irán se convirtiera en una
teocracia regida por la ley islámica y
liderada por el ayatolá Home mini desde
ese momento la realidad del país cambió
por completo la religión pasó a ser
parte central del estado y las mujeres
perdieron muchos de los derechos de los
que gozaban ellas pasaron a depender
completamente de sus familiares primero
de sus padres o hermanos y después de
sus maridos Perdieron el derecho al
divorcio se vieron sometidas a
matrimonios forzados en algunas
ocasiones Y se vieron obligadas a llevar
siempre el hillab en espacios públicos
a pedir permiso a los hombres para poder
estudiar o viajar algo que levantó mucha
polémica algunas activistas de las
mujeres defendían que estas medidas no
eran parte del islam y que la represión
era simplemente una política exclusiva
de los ayatolás
la idea de la mujer islámica es que el
islam dio derecho a las mujeres mucho
antes de que las mujeres de occidente
tuvieran derechos
derechos económicos derechos de herencia
sin embargo este tipo de protestas no
tuvo prácticamente ninguna repercusión
el régimen islámico consiguió
estabilizar su poder durante las décadas
de 1980 y 1990 a pesar de los desafíos
internos contra las guerrillas
opositoras kurdas y de izquierdas y de
los externos como la guerra que asoló
esta nación contra Irak entre 1980 y
1988 o la constante tensión con Estados
Unidos Israel naciones que promovieron
su aislamiento internacional
durante estos más de 40 años de
revolución islámica los cambios en las
normas que rigen a este sistema han sido
realmente escasos a pesar de que la
sociedad iraní ha ido evolucionando poco
a poco Este cambio se siente
especialmente entre las mujeres jóvenes
que han comenzado a llevar ropas más
ajustadas de las que permite el régimen
han optado por maquillarse o permiten
que se vea parte de su cabello cuando
Usan el velo gestos que son muy
perseguidos por la policía de la moral
encargada de supervisar que en todo
momento se cumpla con el estricto código
de comportamiento y vestimenta impuesto
por los ayatolás es en este contexto
sumado con el descontento general por la
crisis económica en el que el asesinato
de masaha Mini ha provocado unas
protestas tan fuertes contra el régimen
de los ayatolás Durante los últimos años
han sido habituales las manifestaciones
en Irán Pero tenían una índole
mayoritariamente económica y estaban
dirigidas contra el gobierno de turno y
no contra el sistema cuando Estas
mujeres rechazan el uso del velo están
atacando a uno de los Pilares
ideológicos fundamentales de la
república islámica Y de ahí se puede
entender la reacción violenta del
régimen este movimiento tan fuerte por
los derechos de las mujeres casi no
tiene precedentes en los últimos 43 años
y aunque es algo muy significativo no es
fácil imaginar que pueda suponer cambios
reales en Irán en la actualidad rige Un
gobierno ultraconservador y parece
complicado que un estado que se ha
caracterizado por la eliminación de toda
disidencia y por su fortalecimiento
armamentístico puede acceder ante unas
protestas civiles con esto concluimos
Gracias por compartir y comentar estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de 24.com
[Música]